hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular armageddon game uh from
round six of the 2022 norway chess it's
wesley saw versus ariantharin and this
game features a move that is uh that is
just incredible it's um it's not okay
it's maybe not uh ninja medina versus
chernikov type of uh
move or or maybe on that level of uh
craziness but uh it's uh
you guys will simply love this one uh so
let's dive straight into it wesley has
the white pieces and he opens with c4 he
tries uh the the english in armageddon
uh we have e6 knights the c3 d5 d4 uh
transposing into the queen's gambit
declined and now c5 uh tardy goes for
the tara's defense c captures on d5 and
now if you want to uh get more chances i
guess you play c captures on d4 but this
is armageddon black only needs a draw to
win the game uh so e captures on the e5
this is the more solid and i believe by
far the most analyzed line knight to f3
and now knight to c6 and now g3 the
so-called schlichter rubinstein system
uh we have knight to f6 and bishop to g2
both players just um develop their
pieces to optimal squares with captures
a trade in the center captures captures
and now bishop to c5 putting pressure on
the knight so knight b3 putting pressure
on the bishop bishop to b6 and now
knight captures on d5 wesley grabs a
pawn but it will be black who will be up
in development as you'll see so bishop
to e6 now threatening uh
another uh threatening but yeah
basically threatening to win the knight
it's attacked three times so you have to
do something about this wesley defends
it and now bishop the g4 attacking the
queen and here there are a couple of
moves that are known in this position
like f3 is unknown move bishop to f3's
unknown move so just contouring the
light square bishop and also queen to d3
is a known move however
the move wesley plays is a new one he
plays queen to d2 and it is now as of
move 12 that we have a completely new
game uh knight captures on the five by
30 e captures on d5 and now queen the e7
with check and you can see that black
really doesn't have any problems playing
this with king to f1 and now queen side
castles making it impossible for uh d
captures on c6 as the queen on d2 is
hanging or so you would think
wesley plays h3 challenges the bishop
creates a little more room here for the
king so you can maybe play king to g1
king h2 in the future bishop to f5 and
now
uh the the move you have to play here as
white is
a queen to f4 this is the
strongest continuation for white however
if this move was played it is very hard
to say if the game would be as exciting
as it was because here wesley played the
d captures on c6 a move that seems
impossible because the queen is hanging
on d2 but he plays it nonetheless the
problem is
as great as this move is and it's really
a beautiful one to see and it's i
believe it's uh an amazing feeling to
play such a move in such a uh
you know strong tournament against such
a strong player the problem is it
completely blunders the game however uh
it's not uh clear why so feel free to
pause the video and uh punish this uh
queen offering uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
white queen does not have access to the
d1 square that's the key to realize in
order to solve this position and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show uh the correct move is b captures
on c6 that's the that's the move and if
tari had found this b captures on c6
idea we would see resigns on the spot
there is no way to continue the game
because once the queen moves let's say
queen f4 we just deliver checkmate queen
rook to d1 is checkmate and the queen
cannot keep an eye on the d1 square you
can't play queen to e2 because if queen
to a2 okay now you do cover it but
bishop d3 wins the queen uh for for a
bishop which isn't all that great and of
course you can't go here c2 is covered
by the bishop uh this is resigns however
uh wesley managed to completely confuse
toddy by playing the captures on c6 and
tari accepted the queen and this now
gives wesley a whole lot of counter play
he plays c captors on b7 now already
getting a pass pawn on b7 as it's
defended by the bishop king the b8 and
now we have bishop captures on d2 with
the terrible threat of bishop to f4 uh
so you have to do something about this
so a6 giving a little bit of breeding
room to the king but the actual okay
this makes sense uh you have to do this
but again the correct idea was bishop to
e4 you just blocked the bishop's defense
of the b7 pawn trade the light square
bishops captured the pawn and then you
are you are perfectly fine and much
better at that
so instead after bishop captures on d2
a6 was played but now it is finally uh
wesley who is who is better in this game
uh rook to e1 uh which tempo the queen
is attacked and now bishop to e4 is no
longer an option so we have queen to f6
king the g1 now wesley wants to bring
the king to h2 and bring this rook into
the game as well uh and you don't really
have any bishop captures on f2 action
here because after king captures there's
just uh not a good discovery to be made
so instead after king g1 bishop to e6
now threatening to capture here uh but
just king h2 not even uh trying to
defend the f2 pawn with bishop therefore
checks or just king h2
bishop captures on f2 would be a mistake
because now bishop for checking a7 and
rook uh h to f1 you lose the bishop or
you move the bishop and then bishop to
b8 check picks up the queen or pretty
much anything wins the game here for
white so instead after king h2 king a7
uh tarry now tries to
hide the king from the dark square
bishop now bishop c3 attacking the queen
grabbing more space here queen captures
on f2 and now rook h to f1
wesley fully mobilizes his forces with
queen to c2 and now knights to d4
attacking the queen so here uh you trade
uh otherwise um
uh it's just uh just a terrible terrible
position there's really not all that
much you can play knight captures on e6
is coming even maybe knight the c6 check
in some lines uh trying to get some uh
discoveries on the king if the queen
moves to a silly square but okay bishop
captures with bishop captures and now uh
king to b8 bishop to e5 check the
position repeats a few times the bishop
d4 became the b8 and now wesley uh
decides to go for rook captures on e6 uh
there are many winning
lines here this one is is just very nice
f captures and now bishop to e5 check
again we repeat a few times bishop d4
king to b8 and now bishop captures on g7
seems like a silly uh
uh time to just grab a pawn but uh this
is uh this is the way to do it uh so
here king rook to e8 and now bishop to
e5 would check uh it's just uh it's just
uh grabbing an extra pawn there's no
danger here for white so king to a7 now
we repeat again bishop d for checking to
b8 bishop to e5 checking to a7 and then
now comes rook to f7 and this is also
winning but uh just for fun i will show
you a really really cool line uh or or
even better you show me a really cool
line uh feel free to pause the video and
try to find the the coolest way possible
to win this for wesley while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being a true
master of tactics and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is b8
uh queen or a rook doesn't really matter
but it's cooler to bring a queen into
the game as it comes with tempo and now
after rook captures we just play bishop
the d4 with check and the king has no
squares that's the good stuff and now
okay you could block with the queen but
that's just winning but if rook to b6
which seems like okay maybe you can
survive this uh rook f8 and there's no
defense against the rook the a8
checkmate so if you found this uh you
have a really really uh good you know uh
skill i i would say at solving tactics
because this was not an easy one to spot
right away so instead rook to f7 wesley
doesn't have to find this if this was
the only winning line of course the
wesley would find it but as every movie
is winning you just have to win uh you
know to to
gain points in the tournament so king to
b6 now comes the b8 with queen rook
captures and bishop characters now white
is just up too much material so of
course black will try with a5 bishop
back to e5 and now pawn to a4 uh rook to
b7 with check and now king to a6 we have
a3 and now uh queen to e2 going after
the bishop but just bishop d4 e5
attacking the bishop and now rook to e7
and now of course you cannot capture as
the queen would hang so h5 and here rook
the e6 check and it was in this position
on move43 that arientari resigned the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
all of the squares here are covered your
only two squares are b5 and a5 and if
king to b5 or king to a5 real captures
an e5 with check we'll just pick up the
queen and of course now it's two bishops
for nothing uh completely winning for
for wesley so really a remarkable game a
remarkable move by wesley this d
captures in c6 such a such a spectacular
uh spectacular move to make and uh of
course if you are uh you know on the
receiving end of this d captures on c6
idea and your opponent is wesley so you
you look at that move and you're like
yeah okay i missed that obviously uh you
know my bad uh but without even thinking
that a silly move like b captures on c6
and white resigns is just incredible and
also one of the reasons why chess is the
greatest the game ever invented uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it let's check out the standings
after round six uh so you guys are
updated uh so magnus is now leading the
tournament as he won his classical game
whereas anand um uh won the uh
armageddon game against anish
wesley with 10 points with eighty and a
half we have maxima shiloh graham and
shakhtar and mohammedara with eight on
each giri aryantari with seven wesleyan
topalov with six wang khao with four and
timur rajab with four points so those
are the uh current standings uh so uh
that's uh the standings as well hope you
guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank raymond young cedar siemens evalia
and lego uh charles huff and david
kimura for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
to my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event hoping that more games
like this will take place uh so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day